oh yes hello hi how's it going have you
ever been working at an office in one
day you want to look up porn what hi
how's it going it's me
markiplier welcome to this game where am
I going away from this [ __ ] video
haha goodbye god this is the worst intro
I've ever done ignore all the insanity
that you just saw
welcome to NSFW or your first day with
us please finish all of your training
videos oh I'll finish all my training
videos alright
right-click to work or have fun I've
been doing yeah yeah a lot of fun 50/50
split on work and fun have you ever been
working one day and you wanted to look
up gratuitous amounts of porn
well now you can simulate it who put all
this poop in my pants he's alive not the
same dog I know my own dog